So aluminium is a metal which was only isolated
in the 19th
century and when it was first isolated it
was fantastically
expensive, it was displayed like gold at exhibitions.
Now you
find it everywhere. For example, you can find
it quite easily
here you have thin foil of aluminium which
is used as the
covering for pill packets. You may easily
have eaten lunch
today from sandwiches what were wrapped up
in aluminium
foil and it’s used in the laboratories in
all sorts of different
ways. It is a very good reflective material
so chemists and
engineers often put aluminium coatings on
mirrors like this
one. Usually if you have a mirror in your
bathroom the metal
coating is at the back, so that when you spit
when cleaning
your teeth you don’t damage the mirror but
when you are
doing experiments particularly with ultra
violet light that is
absorbed by glass, or infra red light as well,
you have this as
a coating on the front of your mirror. So
here you have a
quite nice example of a front coated aluminium
mirror.